foreign
[Music]
depends on it so he's got to do whatever
he can he is very desperate he is
absolutely cornered and he simply has no
manpower to fight the ukrainians
there's basically several waves of
mobilization the people who are getting
the call First are men under the age of
35 who have this military experience
um however under Russian law in practice
there is nothing stopping any
able-bodied man from being drafted
[Music]
I think maybe there's a feeling that
this is too little too late to save the
war effort how motivated are these
troops uh who are being drafted so how
are you suddenly going to train or
retrain 300 000 men so it looks already
like on the battlefield that we're
running out of professional soldiers
[Music]
the mobilization is not gonna impact
because Russia is resorting to its very
old uh military trick of Simply using
endless Cannon folder uh to attack and
attack and attack this time Russia just
simply does not have enough resources
[Music]
thank you
now the war has been brought home so now
it's no longer a special operation
that's taking place over there in
Ukraine it's uh it's coming home and our
Ukraine's had mobilization since the War
Began so now I guess Russians are
getting a taste of that as well
thank you
[Music]